foreign
Julia is with us in Sacramento hi Julia
how are you
hi good how are you it's a pleasure
same here how can we help
my mom recently purchased a timeshare in
Mexico and she paid cash for it
she reached out to me and asked me to
give her my ID and my birth certificate
she wants to modify her trust no
I don't want a timeshare
it's legalized fraud you're gonna get
this is not a blessing this is a curse
why would a loving mother do this to her
daughter because she still thinks it's a
good deal she got screwed no we don't
need to pass this on this is not an
heirloom
yeah she thinks it's a good deal it's
not a good deal it's a horrible deal
there are no good timeshares they suck
100 of them it is one of the worst
products ever put out by man
I hope I wasn't unclear
you were very clear I thought so as well
in my ear he was clear don't make him
say no a third time Julia
yeah just lovingly kindly mom I I'm not
interested in the timeshare thank you
though
okay I don't I don't I I think they're a
really bad deal and I'm really sorry you
bought one mom
and I think you're gonna regret it and
I'd never ever ever ever wanted in my
name no thank you thank you thank you no
I also don't want your dog to bite me
you know this is like
these are let me tell you there's a 97
dissatisfaction rate with timeshare
owners
there's no other product out there in
the world that has a 97 dissatisfaction
rate people that buy them hate them
they're a complete screw job your poor
precious mother got screwed over and
hasn't realized it yet and she's trying
to pass that on as an heirloom no please
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
shall lower the volume for those notes
just for you believe me we all
appreciate it